i'm daniel de broken known as debbie i
am head of engineering at work see in
new york city the next level of
development would be agile development
in which we ask ourselves what are we
going to do the next three weeks and
this is how we work today we'll plan
three weeks worth of features and
priorities and so on and so forth and
then we stop every three weeks we
backtrack look at what we've
accomplished we'll look at everything
that's ahead of us we reprioritize and
then we go and do another three weeks
print when the team grew two maybe three
or four engineers we needed to do a
little bit of planning we couldn't be
walking on each other's shoes and we had
to make sure that there is somebody
working on feature a and somebody
working with it should be and maybe
somebody else doing some infrastructure
work that's when we started doing agile
development and Sprint's where we plant
for a week of work for the small team
then we realize that we could really use
a little bit more planning and try and
do too weak a two-week iteration that
worked even better but we still felt a
little bit short today we do three weeks
prints we do them as a whole company not
just engineering and we were kind of
like a metronome in these three-wicket
aerations where we would start with a
demo from a previous sprint to the
entire company and then a will plan
we'll figure out what we are working on
the next three weeks in terms of
high-level priorities we'll go back to
the drawing board rethinking some of the
features and then will iterate on those
and again download them three weeks into
this